Hello, and welcome to our webcast,
MBA Students Insights: Life Outside Tech
at the GSB.
My name is Jason Dunford.
And I'm a first-year MBA
student here at the GSB.
And I'm joined by JB Monu and
Jessica Holton.
Like me, they are pursuing career
interests outside the tech sector.
So today we'll be talking a little bit
about the student experience here at
the GSB and we'll answer as many
of your questions as we can.
So to submit a question to us about
what it's like to be a student,
just click the Chat button
at the top of your screen,
enter your question, and
click Send to all Panelists.
Please be aware that we won't be taking
any questions about the admission process,
the application, or financial aid today.
You can consult the website or
contact the MBA admissions office for
that information.
All right, let's get started.
We'll begin with introductions,
where we're from, what we were each
doing before coming to GSB, and
what our goals are for after graduation.
So I'll go ahead and start.
Again, my name's Jason Dunford.
I grew up in Kenya, came to the US for
college about ten years ago.
I was an international swimmer,
so I swam during college and
then beyond college representing Kenya.
And then after that I worked
a couple of jobs before the GSB.
The first one was in electronics recycling
and then after that I moved into the solar
industry, and I became very
passionate about clean energy and
see myself working in that
industry beyond the GSB.
Now I'll turn it over to JB.
>> Hi, I'm JB Monu.
I grew up in Upstate New York, but most
recently I've been living in Los Angeles.
Prior to the GSB,
I worked in the entertainment industry.
So I spent four and a half years
at a talent agency, Entourage, and
a year and
a half at a TV production company.
And I'm looking to get into
management consulting, post-GSB.
Thanks, JB, Jessica?
>> Hi, everyone, I'm Jessica,
it's great to be with you here today.
I grew up on the East Coast, primarily New
Jersey and most recently from New York.
And prior to the GSB, I was in finance.
I did two years of investment banking and
two years of private equity,
focusing on the consumer industry.
And post-graduation, I'd love to start
a company in the skin care industry.
>> Great, thank you both.
So let's get started with some
questions submitted by the audience.
So the first one, did you come to school
planning to work outside of tech or
did you change your
plans after you arrived?
JB, you want to take that one first off.
>> Okay, yeah.
My interest was very simple because I
was very deliberate what I wanted to do.
Working entertainment for six years,
I was ready to see more industries, and
I figure the best way to do that
was to go to business school and
then [COUGH] work in consulting because
they work with many different industries.
So I was very focused and
knew what I wanted to do going into it.
>> Yeah, I was also very focused on
wanting to start a consumer company.
What I was really excited about was
just being around the tech industry and
around Silicon Valley and
just understanding the different ways
that people think here on the West Coast.
So while I was never really interested
in going directly into tech,
I was interested in getting
the tech kind of vibe.
>> Great, and for me,
very passionate about energy after
working at Sunrun Solar Company and
now exploring ways to go and work in clean
energy back in Kenya, where I'm from.
Been in the US quite a few years now so
I want to use the knowledge I gain here at
the GSB to go back and do something there.
>> So number two,
what resources have the GSB provided you
with to explore life outside of tech?
Jessica, do you have a-
>> Yeah, so
in starting a company,
Stanford is great at providing resources
that are related to
entrepreneurial pursuits.
Two things that come to mind
are Venture Studio, which is actually
a physical space on campus that you can
work on your company that you're starting.
But there's also a huge
community of people who
are alumni of Stanford who were part
of Venture Studio while they were here.
And they ask questions of each other and
we've kind of provided resources for
each other.
In addition, classes like Startup Garage
offer a hands-on experience and
a really agnostic to what industry
you're wanting to start a company in.
So they have a huge focus
on providing resources for
entrepreneurial ventures, and
it doesn't matter if it's tech or not.
>> Okay, JB?
>> Yeah, so even though I knew
I wanted to do consulting,
I still went to a number of those CMC,
Career Management Center, events.
And they have a lot of different events
to help you just explore who you are, and
explore what you're interested in.
It gives you ideas of what to get into.
So I knew I wanted to do consulting,
but I said, you know what?
Let me try these out, and
they're actually pretty helpful.
I noticed they help out a lot of people.
It helped me even focus
more on consulting.
So, CMC is a great resource, too.
>> And for me, a bit like Jessica,
I've had a chance to be part of
Venture CO, exploring my own venture.
And also taking a couple of classes,
what we call across the street classes,
in other schools here at Stanford.
So I had a great opportunity to take
a energy entrepreneurship class last
quarter, and really progress
the venture that I'm working on.
>> Great, we'll move on to the next one.
What academic extracurricular internship
experiences are helping you explore and
pursue careers outside of tech?
JB, I'll throw that one over to you.
>> Yeah, well, having a liberal arts
degree and not knowing business speak,
as I'll call it, just going to business
school in general is very helpful.
Just the basic,
the introductory strategy class, and
learning how people in
the traditional business world speak.
That alone has been very helpful, and then
the different clubs and stuff as well.
>> Yeah, I would say, too.
Yeah, I mean, for me I'm kind of similar.
I had a Human Biology degree, so
to me really getting the hardcore business
skills has been incredibly helpful as I
think about what I'm going to do next.
And then extracurricularly,
I'm getting a chance to head up
the Stanford Energy Club, which I think
will be a great leadership experience and
help me plug into the energy
community even deeper.
>> All right, that's the next one.
Can you talk about the social
aspects of the community?
Does it feel like everyone
is only interested in tech?
Jessica, that's it?
>> [LAUGH] Absolutely not.
One of my favorite things about
the GSB is how different we all are.
And of course, we are extremely
supportive of each other, but
seeing where people come from and where
they're going, there's really no focus.
I think there's probably a slight
focus to wanting to start a company or
be part of an early-stage startup,
but from an industry perspective,
people are all over the place.
And I'm really excited
to see where people go.
>> Yeah, I would just have to second that,
especially coming from the entertainment
industry, which is definitely different.
I know a number of people
who have even come to me.
Actually, I'm a VP for
the Arts, Media & Entertainment Club,
who want to get into the business.
I know firsthand how difficult it is to
get in there because it's just so opaque.
So yeah, l would just have to second that.
Everyone is interested in so
many different things.
>> Absolutely grand, so
that's incredibly helpful for
people breaking into media MBA.
Okay, great.
Let's see, next we have a question a
little bit more about academics in class.
So how are the industries
incorporated into class discussions?
What classes do this really well,
and do you have a favorite case?
So JB?
>> Overall, I think many different
classes do this very well actually.
I think we should all answer it.
>> Yeah.
>> My favorite case came
from our marketing class.
It was actually a case on Unilever
in Brazil which is they create soap.
So you wouldn't think it's very
interesting, but it was in a sense
because they were trying to figure out
a way to break into a certain market.
And we were in different groups,
and you have to do a whole report.
And it was just cool seeing how all
the different solutions each group
came up with and then presented.
So that was a very fun case,
and obviously not tech related.
>> At all.
>> Yeah.
>> My favorite class has always
been formation of new ventures.
I don't know if you guys have taken it.
But the premise is every class,
we have a different case.
And it's across all industries,
healthcare, financials, tech, consumer.
And we diagnose what happens in a startup.
And each class, the founder comes in and
talks to us and provides their
remarks throughout the class as well.
And so probably my favorite case for that
was a company called Tiny Prints, which
does cards customized and at the time that
something that wasn't available to people.
And hearing the founders and
how they bootstrapped it and
how they built it from the ground
up was really inspiring for me.
And for me, similarly,
with regards to having a class one that
stands out is my HR class where we did
a case on a company in Kenya called
Juhudi Kilimo that did loans to
farmers to increase productivity.
And they finally came in to talk to
us about issues about incentivizing
workers and their field staff to
go out there and get in business.
And that was fascinating.
And for me, as someone who comes from
abroad, it's really cool to see how they
integrate cases from all over
the world into many of these classes.
>> Great, let's see, next question.
How have you kept yourself from
being pressured into tech with
Silicon Valley so close by?
Definitely, there is a pull there, so-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Jessica?
>> Yeah, Stanford does a great job
at two things, well, many things.
But two in particular are reflection and
prioritization.
So in the very beginning of the year
we had a session about priorities, and
setting your priorities.
And really making sure that you're
focusing on your priorities, rather than
being pulled into the community think and
what you think everyone else is doing.
So that's definitely bled
through my entire experience.
I think also on reflection, making sure
that you're in tune with yourself and
what you want to be doing.
It's something that is known as
something that people do here.
So I think that that has
really kept me on my track.
And I haven't really swayed from it
because of those two activities.
>> Yeah, I completely agree.
And one thing I'd also add,
too, is because Stanford is so
close to Silicon Valley, and
there is some slight tech focus,
you get to see how tech has
entered other industries.
Just because you're not going to
go into the tech industry doesn't
mean technology's not changing industries.
So it's actually very cool
to understand that, okay,
I might not go into tech itself.
I might not go to work at Google or Apple,
but technology is changing
all different industries.
And it's good to see that and
keep that in the back of your mind as
you figure out what you want to do.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
And on that point, again that opportunity
to maybe step across to other schools and
take a CS class.
A lot of business students will do that
to get that grounding in the tech field.
>> Great, so what resources are available
to help you pursue a career shift?
Okay, well I can take, you want to go?
>> Yeah, I think, I mean, for me,
the CMC are incredibly helpful,
that's the Career Management Center.
You can go there,
they have a ton of resources,
they have a ton of job kind of advisors,
so that I think is a big one.
JB?
>> Yeah, I was also just going to add,
GMC and the student clubs too,
I joined the Consulting Club.
I remember consulting, recruiting
as an undergrad a little bit, and
thought that was just too difficult.
But the consulting club, and so
there are many different clubs, but
they give you the resources you need,
and the practice you need.
And then because everyone
at the GSB comes from so
many different backgrounds that the
students here are very helpful as well,
if you're looking to change your career.
>> Yeah, just think if you have
a picture of that, being able to,
in the first quarter, have 30 minute
coffee chats with people from, we
have 400 people in our class and I want to
learn about energy or entertainment.
We have 30 minutes and
that really gives also deep dive
really quickly and efficiently.
Right, what is a typical day like at
the GSB, if there is indeed a typical day?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Jessica,
do you have a day you could talk about?
>> Yeah, they're very different.
I would say during the week we're in
classes, it depends on the day, but
probably average of three classes a day,
three to four classes a day.
So we spend a lot of class time, and
we also kind of interspersed with that
have lunch or coffee with people who we're
trying to get to know or catch up with.
For dinner, there's often meetings
where speakers come in, and
you kind of go to that speaker,
and there's dinner provided.
One of my favorite things
about the GSB is Talk,
which is tonight,
every Wednesday night for us,
where one student gives a 30-minute
kind of talk about his or her life.
So that's a good community aspect.
I would say every day has an element of
academic social community and career.
And it's really exciting.
No day is the same, and
they all go very quickly.
>> Yeah, JB?
>> Yeah, the only thing I would say is
typical is you know you're going to
have classes at the same time,
like Monday, Friday, or Tuesday, Thursday.
And then your calendar, you get
invited to lots of different things.
And it just starts to fill up, especially
if you like to say yes, which you should,
because you get to see lots
of different experiences.
So yeah, there's really no typical day.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know about you two, but I find
my calendar pretty much owns my life.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] So I know that I'm there.
>> I'm working on-
>> And then we have our social events,
which is a great time to
get the classwork done for
the following week, and prep for that.
>> Okay, will you talk about
the global experiences you've had or
plan on pursuing?
>> Okay, I can take that one.
As a former athlete, I got a chance
to travel all over the world but
unfortunately, well, it was incredibly
fortunate that on those trips it would
oftentimes just be a pool and a hotel.
So being very nice for me just having
recently gone on a global experience
trip through the GSB to South Africa
with 30 of my classmates.
And we really got to explore the country,
talk to some incredible
leaders down there.
So that's been a new travel experience for
me.
And I'm hoping I can do a few more
of those during my time here.
>> Yeah, similarly, I went on a global
study trip to Singapore and Indonesia.
And just so you know the global
study trips are 30 students,
and you're meeting every day with
business leaders, and government leaders.
It's a really great way to get to
know a country besides the tourism.
So I did that, and
I'm also doing an internship at London for
four weeks over the summer
which will be great, and
then looking into planning
a global study trip for next year.
So the GSB definitely does a great
job at intermingling your kind of
global experiences with
your academic pursuits.
>> Yeah, I mean the global
experience is a requirement so
you have to do some global effort.
I did a global study trip to Japan
last winter, which was just amazing.
And applying for a GMIX,
so we'll see if I get it.
So hopefully four weeks somewhere abroad.
>> And you want to explain
a little bit about what a GMIX is?
>> Yeah, so GMIX is basically,
from the way I see it,
we have 14 weeks I think it is,
yeah, 14 weeks off for summer.
It's a mini internship so
instead of a ten-week or eight-week
internship, generally around four weeks.
It can be flexible depending
on how much time you have.
Where you get like a stipend to live
in a certain country and work for
a company, just really get to
immerse yourself in the experience.
>> It's a really great way to have like a
little snapshot into what it would be like
to work abroad or
in that particular industry, too.
It's a good way just to try it out for
four weeks.
>> Right.
>> The next question,
what exposure do you have to clean tech,
renewables, energy efficiency at the GSB?
>> [LAUGH] I suppose this one's for me.
So there are some GSB classes that
are focused on clean energy
development and demands.
And then, of course,
the engineering department,
there's a ton of classes you can take,
and design your schedule that way.
And a lot of people interested in
environment can also do a dual degree.
It's called a EI degree and
you stay on for an extra quarter.
And it evens dives deeper
into those subjects.
How does social impact and corporate
social responsibility emerge in your GSB
experience, whether inside or
outside class?
Question for you-
>> I know ethics was one of my favorite
classes first quarter, and so
that's a class where you're really
dealing with the difficult questions.
Now the way it's taught, the teacher
does not tell you what's right or wrong.
They just have you,
they talk about business situations,
like the Libor scandal I forgot what
Intel was talking about changing
their supply chain to have safer minerals
and it's basically worked on their own.
And again, so that's definitely a class
that focuses on those as people have those
discussions, because I do
think it's very important.
>> And also there's
a Social Innovation Club here.
The Energy Club, actually,
we collaborate with them sometimes,
they do a big social innovation retreat.
So it's certainly there's a community
you can plug into in a big way.
>> There are also opportunities to be
a part of actual companies who are doing
social good and consulting for them.
And it's a pretty time-intensive thing but
those people are learning a lot.
>> And the last thing I want to add and
I haven't quite done it yet but
you can talk to your professors in class,
so you can challenge them and
ask them certain questions.
I only bring this up because
I'm listening to an audio book
about the financialization of America and
it's talking certain things.
I remember learning certain
things in finance and
I know in the future if I hear something.
This is a little jargon, you can challenge
your professors and be like why is this?
I heard this and I heard that and
it can actually foster very good
discussions actually, right?
>> Excellent,
how supportive is the student body?
Do you feel that it is a competitive
environment or supportive community?
Jessica, do you have a good-
>> I have a very strong opinion on this.
It's incredibly supportive.
I have never been in
a community of people that is,
we're full of 400 cheerleaders
by our sides to help us out.
I've never felt someone is
trying going to ahead and
do something without bringing
the whole class behind them.
I think some significant examples
are in the first quarter,
in the second quarter when some
people had finance backgrounds or
accounting backgrounds would just
to help out and for nothing.
Just spend many hours trying to help
their classmates who came from liberal
arts backgrounds and
it's really just a community of help.
And people know that I'm interested
in starting a skin care company and
people have reached out to me to
want to share their experiences.
And it's really a very,
very special community and
I don't think there's anything like it.
>> Yeah, I totally second that.
And yeah, if you want someone to
help you out with the contacts,
the industry they're interested in,
people are just so willing to do that.
And I'm just thinking only sometimes when
you work in a group project maybe you
don't have a stronger background
that someone else on your team.
I just find people so
willing to help coach and
bring you up to speed
in those experiences.
So it's simply amazing.
>> And I specifically did recruiting for
consulting, which can scare some people,
because generally business schools
are feeders into consulting.
And one, it was nice that Stanford has
such a diversed background that it
wasn't the, again,
I'm remembering undergrad.
There's 200 people in one room,
all fighting for ten jobs.
Stanford didn't feel that way at all,
because one is 40 people and
then people are just so collaborative.
So even in the intense
recruiting of it all,
Stanford is still an incredibly
collaborative and supportive community.
>> And one thing to bring up on
that is that we have a norm of
non-grade disclosures.
So that also helps out.
People kind of are on the spectrum of
being super focused on academics and
also prioritizing other things as well.
And so not competing for the number one or
number two spot, it's not relevant for us.
>> Yeah, and allowing us to take risks and
may be take a class that is,
we don't have a strong background in and
we can really try to push ourselves.
What networking opportunities
available to non-tech students?
>> I can talk about
through the Energy Club.
We host a careers event in collaboration
with the Stanford Energy Club every year.
We're bringing in speakers, we have
brown bag lunches throughout the year.
So we try to do that through the club.
I don't know.
>> Yeah, I would echo that for
the Retail Club.
Obviously, as you can tell,
we have clubs that go kind of by industry
in addition to other activities and
one thing that the clubs do,
at least the Retail Club, is a trek.
So there was a trek to Europe but the one
that I went on was to San Francisco, so
it was half an hour away.
I'm meeting with various companies, I'm
really getting to know people within those
companies and networking across retails
systems, for Chubbies and other places.
>> How invested as GSB in
providing recruiting resources for
students who are interested
in careers outside of tech?.
>> What a similar question, I don't know-
>> I think
we've touched on this a little bit.
But again, the CMC and the clubs do such
an amazing job of giving you the resources
you would need no matter what.
Again, we talked about the treks, we
talked about the CMC and on the different,
you can use individual one-on-one
meetings if you're a CMC advisor,
they can help you reach out to alumni.
There's plenty of resources
that will help you and
can find jobs outside of tech.
>> Yeah.
>> Right,
can you speak a bit about any
experience you might have meeting
students at GSB who come
from a nonprofit background
who are interested in focusing on
nonprofits later in their careers?
>> Personally, I have a lot of friends
who come from nonprofit backgrounds,
and a couple that comes to mind actually
starting a company in this space.
And so Stanford is incredibly supportive
for people who want to get into nonprofit.
There's also funding you can access for
your summer to work with
nonprofit companies and then there's also
a fellowship beyond, once you graduate
that you can access, if you're going to
be working in a nonprofit career.
So the GSB is incredibly supportive.
Anything else to add on that one?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Is it common for
student's post-grad goals to change
over the course of the program?
>> Definitely,
I think a lot of people come in not
really knowing what they want to do,
knowing that they want to change fields
but want to explore different hypotheses.
I think it'll be interesting,
we're all first years.
So it'll be interesting to see what
happens after the summer where a lot of
people have internships and they test
out the hypothesis of do they like it or
do they not or various aspects.
And then come back in the fall
ready to do full-time recruiting or
go back to the company
that they interned at.
It'll be interesting to see.
>> And it's currently almost May,
we're a week away from May, and
I know a number of people who still
don't have internships for the summer.
And it's not because they
can't get internships,
its because they're still just really
trying to figure out what they want to do.
So even right now, some people are still
trying to figure out where to explore.
>> We're waiting for the perfect-
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah, I've had heard from the second
years. This summer can be a big time,
because it really helps refine how
you approach the second year and
really hanging on something.
>> Knowing you wanted to enter a non-tech
field before entering business school,
why did you choose GSB?
>> I can talk about that one.
GSB, it was definitely my top
choice when I lived in Los Angeles.
So even though I grew up in the Northeast,
it would be nice to stand in the West
Coast and I'm doing this whole thing
short term, I might want to
get back as a media long term.
But what I was saying earlier, this is how
technology is changing every industry.
So I wanted to be nearby the tech
space specifically in media.
I mean,
Facebook is becoming a media company.
Apple is having a much bigger
space in the media space,
bigger play in the media space.
So these tech companies are becoming
media companies from my point of
view, in a sense.
So I just wanted to be around that
sort of life, I guess, in proximity.
>> Yeah, I agree.
I wanted to be around the big ideas and
ideas that are changing the world and
just open this, a new ways of thinking and
collaborating, and
the GSB was definitely that.
Beyond that, I think the community
that we have all talked about is just
unparalleled and that's really
what made GSB my first choice.
And then I'd also say that if
you want to start a company,
those resources are unparalleled as well.
I think it's a fantastic place to start
a company regardless of what industry you
want to started in.
>> Mm-hm, yeah and, I was lucky enough
to do my undergraduates here, so-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Any time [CROSSTALK] farmer,
I'll take it.
>> [LAUGH] How much does your first and
second year schedules allow for
you to be in extracurriculars?
Is it recommended to do
just one extracurricular,
like take a new leadership role or would
you be able to participate in a few clubs?
>> So clubs here are different from,
at least my undergrad experience, in that
they don't really dominate your social
experience if you don't want them to.
So we have something called,
we have the first five weeks.
Basically, we can't be apart of club and
that's in an effort to get back in
the swing of things of being a student and
getting to know your classmates.
And so by the time you join, it's actually
the midway through your first quarter.
And I don't know about you guys,
but I joined several.
The reason our club being one of them,
but also just actively,
it's like the Wine Circle and
the Eat Club.
And so, throughout your first year,
you can definitely be
involved in a bunch of them.
And then, if you want to take
on a leadership position,
it's definitely manageable,
and I'm doing one.
It's the Eating Club.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's definitely manageable.
It's kind of like,
whatever you want to prioritize is
where you should spend your time.
>> Yeah, I would agree.
I mean, in terms of club leadership,
I think, it really depends.
One, how much the club does over the
course of the year, how big a role it is,
how much you want to bring to the role.
I do see some people take on maybe more
than one leadership role in a club,
but I think typically it's one and
then being a member or
playing a supporting role in the club.
>> But I've definitely seen
like some second years.
They're done now, but like who, we had
a couple of clubs, one or two clubs.
They did Arbuckle.
I met someone who was like an Arbuckle
fellow, and also saw [LAUGH] and
like planned a gimmick too.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they were very, very, very busy
because that is a lot, but it's doable.
>> Right.
>> With a non-tech bias, how does
the GSB prepare you for starting for
profit businesses in Africa or
low income countries?
>> This is fun for me.
[LAUGH] So, I mean, there have been
quite a few businesses started in
these countries by alums of the GSB.
So I have plugged into the network, people
who've done that in Kenya specifically.
Again, there's a ton of resources,
people who've funded businesses overseas.
So there's a lot of potential.
A lot of innovations have come out of
Stanford for work in low income countries.
One I can think of specifically
came out of the d.school
was a low tech incubator for
babies in low income countries.
So there's a lot of support here and
there's a lot of precedent for
people who have done that
coming out of the GSB.
[INAUDIBLE] more generally, actually.
>> Can you talk about your
experiences with faculty?
>> I've had great experience with faculty.
And it's just funny thinking, comparing
it to my undergrad experience, right?
Didn't really talk to faculty at all that
often, but I've had a couple of lunches.
Accounting, I was terrified for
accounting because that was just a class
tat was going to be, this was going to
be the toughest thing from a non-business
background, but I love the class.
I had lunch with the teacher
while we were in class together.
I've had lunch with the teacher
again like after class.
So the faculty is just
incredibly approachable.
We, because the way the school is
setup is the big right in the middle.
So you see your teachers even like when
you're not in class with them anymore and
like, it's just fun to catch up with them.
So I've just had amazing
experiences with faculty members.
>> Yeah, I'd say they were
deeply supportive just like
the community of us is.
And so I had a question about a start up,
and I went in to talk to a professor for
office hours, and she spent way
longer than I expected her to or
to have time to because she really cared
about getting to the bottom of it and
problem solving with me.
And it's an ongoing conversation.
So it's really actually incredible
how much they want to help us and
want to see us succeed and
propel us into the world.
>> I second all of that, and I actually,
just last week, had an amazing experience
where I got invited to go to an ice
hockey game with a faculty member.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We got to spend time watching
the San Jose Sharks.
[LAUGH] Pretty incredible, so.
[LAUGH]
>> And I've actually got more thing like
there was one teacher who,
half way through the quarter,
you do evaluation of your teachers.
And one teacher, we didn't love him.
We gave him not a very strong evaluation.
But the way he responded
to it was incredible to me.
He took it, and then he spent one class
literally just talking to us about what
he could do better, how he can improve,
his experiences from prior years.
And the second half of the class went so
much better because that teacher
really cared about changing the way
he was teaching us, the engagement.
>> What support and
guidance do alumni provide?
>> I can take that.
I mean, I've had just really
amazing interactions with alumni,
especially ones involved in energy.
I've had a lot of conversations that way.
There's actually a standard
professionals in energy group where
they help set us up with mentors who
work in the field outside the GSB.
So incredibly supportive alumni community,
I think that's one of
the huge pluses of the GSB is that
community you get to plug into.
>> I definitely think it's because
it's a much tighter community that you
can really connect with alumni.
[LAUGH] I remember, especially during
the recruiting process or consulting,
a [LAUGH] number of alumni were definitely
reaching out to me and saying, hey,
you should think about this firm.
Our firm is pretty good.
And so, I just had good
interactions with them as well.
>> Yeah, people are incredibly
welcome to the emails and cold emails.
If you have a Stanford address,
they are definitely welcome
to answering your questions.
>> Great, so
we're almost out of time today.
Before we go, JB and Jessica,
any final words of advice for
people thinking about applying
to Stanford for an MBA?
>> I would probably say, look into
the community that you're joining.
I think Stanford is an incredible
community, but it is one that is a pretty
intense community and one that really does
to open up and share with each other and
get to know each other really well.
I don't know if that's for everyone.
It's definitely for me and
it works really well for me.
But just really understands
the community that you're joining and
where you will play into that.
>> Yeah, and I would say, just be really
thoughtful about what you want to get
out of the experience, but then be also
open at the same time because like,
you understand you're going to change.
So come in with a goal,
like a loose sort of goal,
and leave yourself open to change.
>> I guess my final comment would be if
you know you don't want to work in tech,
there's plenty of other opportunities
that you can explore in the GSB side.
So I don't think that should be a big
concern as you were thinking about
Stanford for an MBA.
It's an incredible experience for
me so far, yeah, and
definitely seconded as well.
>> Great, okay, well, that's it.
Thank you too for joining us and everyone
in the audience who are participating, you
can learn more about the MBA program and
the admission process on the GSB website.
The application for
the next cycle will be available in June.
Yeah, thanks again and
I hope you all have a great day.